vancouver thank you all for the canadian
love i had a great weekend up there you
guys are the [ __ ] best the tour rolls
on y'all edmonton i'll be there in a
couple of weeks september 29th through
october 1st chicago i will see you guys
in november the 11th and the 12th and
grand rapids i'll see you all december
9th
and 10th get your tickets to those shows
and all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night
pants studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social medias
listen thank you for your support this
show grows and grows because of you and
i can't thank you enough if you are
watching please hit that damn subscribe
button on youtube all right
uh if you gotta have more check out the
patreon it's called the honeydew with
y'all and i'm highlighting the low
lights with you all and i'm telling you
you all have the wildest stories i've
ever heard in my life and i mean just
through my life of sitting and talking
to strangers on buses and planes and
[ __ ] the craziest stuff i've ever heard
in my life it is five bucks a month if
you sign up for a year you get over a
month free you get the honey do a day
early you get it ad free you get it at
no
additional cost if you or someone you
know has a story where it just it has to
be heard please submit the honeydew
podcast gmail.com hopefully we get to do
an episode together all right night
pants nation tour continues to roll on
into the fall and winter vancouver
september 15th through the 17th edmonton
september 29th through october 1st
chicago november 11th and the 12th in
grand rapids i will be there december
9th
and 10th that's the business y'all you
guys know we do over here we highlight
the low lights i always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
i am very excited to have today's guest
back on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome kim kong and
welcome back wow thank you i'm so
excited to be back well we had a really
great fun episode listen i'm going to
say this before we even get into this if
you haven't seen kim's first episode you
got one of the clips went viral uh
talking about uh was it an aunt and her
nephew yeah who they call it uh having
an affair yeah uh your mom and aunt the
storm the storm through all of florida
um great episode so thank you for being
back yeah thank you for having me you're
welcome before we get into
whatever we are uh gonna talk about plug
all of it okay yeah um you guys can
follow me on twitter kimberlycongdon on
instagram at kimcongden uh check me out
on twitch if you're into that twitch.tv
queen kong one um and you guys can check
out both my podcast um one of them is
called broad topics t-o-p-i-x
and the other one's called this [ __ ]
with sarah weinshank so good yeah um and
you can find both of those anywhere you
find podcasts and um
please go follow subscribe it's free
um and i will be at skankfest in vegas
october 15 through 17th so make sure you
get tickets for that if it's not already
sold out
all right so
second episode here we're sitting down
talking about more because we really
only like you said you went back and
listened we didn't get into too many
stories so i was surprised you're from
florida originally yes and your mom is
from where is she also florida my mom's
puerto rican she's from puerto rico but
she okay she was born in puerto rico
yeah but when i was born we came to
florida gotcha yeah
and what was your dad's background again
my dad is well his family is from kansas
but his mom was part native american as
well okay but she would always she
she seems super native american for a
very white woman so i don't know a lot
of turquoise
she just had all these black and white
photos she was everywhere
like she took like pictures of pictures
of that pocahontas cartoon and put them
in black and white and put them in
frames she was like these are our
cousins
um but yeah um my dad's white
essentially but he's
he he lived in puerto rico for a long
time so he speaks like fluent spanish is
that where he met your mom yes okay so
they came here together yeah so he came
back and brought her yeah all right yeah
yeah he said it was the worst mistake of
his life
listen that's so funny you say that
because
he just made me
my dad would drive me and my two
brothers and whenever we would pass by
the church where he got married he would
be like that was the worst thing that's
what he would say because there's
then her [ __ ] mom came and her
brother came
they all came left [ __ ] puerto rico
because he have a second accent yeah and
he speaks fluent spanish yeah does he
have the southern accent when he speaks
spanish uh no all right he speaks
spanish spanish
that's hilarious he's a surfer
it wouldn't i wouldn't say it's super
southern but it's um
it's withdrawal
yeah yeah yeah you sound like you're
from like north carolina or something i
get it a lot
maryland's got an accent maryland's a
weird place yeah for dialect yeah and
and in general um
you know it's it's so funny that i'm
bringing up these stories now because
when you
you don't realize when you're a kid
that things are [ __ ] up
right and you don't realize until you're
an adult so this is like a story that i
was just telling a friend and then in
the middle of it i just started slowing
down and being like uh realizing how
weird it was but my grandparents growing
up we would spend like a lot of the time
in the summers when my mom would work at
my grandparents house and um they lived
at well my grandma lived at this like
apartment complex and there was also
like
other kids there that were um you know
either visiting their parents or their
grandparents and we would play with the
neighborhood kids and there was this one
guy
i would okay so i would go and play with
this girl i don't remember her name but
she was my age and then her little
sister was my little sister's age so it
was perfect so we'd go over there and it
was really crazy that my mom would let
me like into their house or into their
apartment because their dad was like
obviously very mentally ill
but we didn't realize it as kids like as
kids we thought that he was like cool
we thought he was like what was he like
he was like he told us that he could
read minds and that he um that like he
heard voices
and he always he was like like thinking
back on it he was creepy as [ __ ] he was
huge he was bald he had glasses but he
was always so nice to us and he was just
their dad and he was their dad and he
loved them and he was like very sweet to
them and they you know but he was very
obviously disturbed he had all these
like paintings and like pen scribble and
they'd be like all these disturbed faces
and then i remember at one point like it
was the wife
there was no wife they were visiting
their dad oh he just is a visit this is
a single dad weekend every other weekend
they were going there for the weekend
and that's and then we would go play
with them and and you know he and
nothing ever bad ever happened like he
was never like inappropriate with us or
and he was a very nice guy but next door
to him we would all be playing outside
and when i would have to walk to his
house there would be this guy at the
archway and he was like
very disabled
like on his stephen hawking's vibes
chair yeah in the chair
you know
body shape of a dead ant
like
you know what i mean
he was like
and
as a kid i was like always very like i
was a very sweet kid so i would try and
like wave to him and how old are you at
this time like seven eight
i have to be nine eight to nine
would be about the age and my sister
no my sister was like
four
yeah so i'm about nine
um and i you know i would wave and he
wouldn't wave back and i would feel bad
and i'd run into my friend's house and i
remember the kids behind us who were
like more bad they were like teaching us
how to cuss they were like don't wave to
him he's a [ __ ] pervert and i was
like what and then one day the next day
i'm coming and he has got his dick out
no he's the same position i don't even
know how he got it out dude it doesn't
even look like i can't even i couldn't
figure out how you got the zipper i was
like
i was more shocked by the mechanism
she gets paid to help him be a pervert
caregiver
um yeah no he's just got his dick out
and he's just staring at us and and then
and then like me and my sister ran is
he's just sitting there he's just
sitting there with his dick out
and he's kind of smiling he's into this
this is like his thing and so yeah
and so and yeah and this was like the
beginning of the summer this is like my
first experience with it so we ran and
we told the kids and like yeah he does
that that's why we don't wave to him
that's what they said and so for the
rest of the summer when we'd play
outside he had on his wheelchair so he
didn't get hit by cars he had a red a
literal red
[Laughter]
because the apartment complex was like a
really poor neighborhood so it was
behind like a dollar general and like it
was like behind like this warehouse all
this [ __ ] so it'll be a bunch of behind
the publix so it was like behind all
this [ __ ] and there was like a bunch of
cars and stuff but you'd see that little
red flag come in and we go jerry and
we'd run
yeah
it was so funny that the flag was right
i didn't realize when i was a kid but
you would see it
waving in the wind
that is hilarious yeah
yeah i am we had a guy that we were
warned about you know what i mean like
he was like the weirdo and i think he
had gotten in trouble or something and
he worked for like the fire department
we would go play bingo and [ __ ] maybe
like that guy right there that you know
parents will tell you like
and i just remember being in the
bathroom one time and he came in and i'm
peeing and he's next to me and i i'm
finishing
i got to wash my hands and he goes make
sure you wash your hands
and listen
i'm probably
seventh eighth grade and i already
wasn't a kid that took [ __ ] you know
what i mean my mother was beating the
[ __ ] out of me i wasn't i didn't care
right and um this guy's like make sure
you wash your hands if you want to be my
buddy and i turn around i'm in there by
myself and i said i don't want to be
your buddy
i go you touch gifts
you said that yeah then i got the [ __ ]
out of it no
yeah you touch kids man
yup we had not even roasting the
molester we had we had a guy yep at um
i had to go to uh i'm like i was raised
catholic so we had to be we had to go to
confirmation okay in order to go to
confirmation they make you do these
classes and all one of them was like a
lock-in you know i don't know you've
been in one of these [ __ ] church
lock-ins okay yeah it was
it's like a sleepover yeah
they make they guilt you they make you
write every bad thing you've ever done
on paper and burn it in front of
everyone it's just guitar circles over
here and [ __ ] people are secretly
fingering each other 100 what i was
about to say there's definitely a finger
corner going over a lot of corners at
every church
every church there's one thing and every
church has one stinky finger at least
our lady of the stinky finger
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] pastor comes up to us youth
pastor okay and he just comes up to me
and my buddy and he's like
this is better than staying home on a
saturday night and jerking off isn't it
that's what he said that's what he says
and i'm telling you we didn't know we
didn't look at each other or anything i
i didn't know he was gonna speak he
didn't know i was going to speak and i'm
just looking right at this dude and i go
no and he says it at the same time we're
just both going
we were friends forever dude
[ __ ] this guy what are you coming to
talk about like
[ __ ] those creepy dudes man dude church
was weird church is a weird place
growing up i remember i was there for
the bagels and the bagels only we didn't
have bagels in my house my mom wasn't
like a bagel it's not like puerto rican
have bagels i guess
and i was never had them until middle
school when someone had them at their
house church introduced me to but
untoasted bagels which is a whole
different story
fresh soft soft bagels with some cream
cheese i'll take that all day underrated
yeah very
but yeah church is creepy writing down
your sins i was like eight years old i'm
like i don't
couldn't think of anything that i had
done super wrong so then i started
guilting myself all night being like
maybe i am mean to my mom yeah and also
like to go into a booth
and there's just this person on the
other side that i'm not allowed to see
i'm just supposed to tell them the the
worst [ __ ] i've done
[ __ ] it i want him to tell me the worst
[ __ ] he's done tell me what you do do
you even have pants on over there bro
you know a lot of them just jack off to
sins
not them jacking off to sin i was
speeding the other day
85 and a 50.
that's the kind of [ __ ] i would say i
curse a little bit i just lie you know
i'm lying in my [ __ ] or is it fun to
go in there and just say really bad [ __ ]
i'm lying right now yeah just killed
three people yeah
um tell me more tell me about
you well you said you used to tempt
these this is crazy to do that so yeah
so when
well yeah there's something about being
a kid in florida you get real bored
and i remember well this were you like i
don't mean interrupt because i'm gonna
get yelled at for it but were you and
outside play outside a lot kids yes okay
yeah obviously you can only get in
trouble if you play outside a lot i've
had what are ipad kids doing
they're just [ __ ] inside getting
virtually molested on roblox yeah you're
right they're getting it too over there
yeah um
but yeah i was outside a lot like we
like the same thing we knew the one
guy's house to stay away from and that
was the house that whenever we had
friends over on our bikes we'd be like
let's go throw rocks at that dude's
window like all the kids were
abusing the abuser in our neighborhood
um but yeah me and my best friend she
was
um
so bad when we were younger i was like
the anxious one like i was always like
no we're gonna get in trouble and she
was like growing up my memory
is like me being like no we can't sneak
out and her halfway out the window going
if you want to be a loser just stay and
me being like all right i'm coming like
just like the movies like it was just
like that was that was her and um we
would get on aol instant messenger aim
and we would go into chat rooms
and we would start talking to people and
tell them like our real age like we'd be
like we're 13. i remember at this point
i think we were 12 doing this
and we would tell like men that we're 12
and then we'd tell them
like
we would give them an address to meet us
and we would go and like hold on they're
entertaining you back the whole time
yeah we would talk to them for sometimes
for days
we would build like relationships with
somebody and you know they're we were
the original chris hanson sweetie
yeah and then we would we would give
them the address
yeah
then we would give them an address to a
park in the neighborhood where in the
neighborhood where we lived and we would
go and hide and just watch them wait for
it they would they would show up
a couple of times a couple of did you
tell your parents or the police because
we liked them just looking dumb waiting
for kids and ghosted them yes and then
we would just laugh and go home be like
let's go smoke a cigarette out of your
mom's thing
your mom's
your mom's ashtray i'm seeing a lot of
scary headlines about inflation rent
increases the coming recession but
there's good news inflation has changed
real estate and there are new
opportunities for first time home buyers
if you've been waiting on the sidelines
for the market to change
now is the time to start planning that's
why i keep recommending the how to buy a
home podcast host david cedoni's an
industry expert who lays out what to
expect from the housing market right now
and what you can do today to take
advantage david cedoni has years of
experience helping first-time home
buyers figure out their own path to home
ownership his podcast has helped so many
listeners close on their first home plus
he just released a first-time homebuyer
starter kit at howtobuyahome.com
it's a free resource with all the
knowledge you need to buy your first
home
thousands of people have already taken
advantage of the starter kit and it can
help you too start planning for the
coming recession at howtobuyahome.com
and make this the last year you rent
find how to buy a home on youtube and
wherever you listen to podcasts it's too
nice out to be too damn high i get it
just because we've aged out of summer
break doesn't mean we don't need to
chill out ditch the munchies paranoia
and potency
of today's weed with that grass that
grass is legal organic hemp that relaxes
your body and mellows your mind that
grass cbd products are made with 100
organic hemp that's easy to dose and the
effects come on smooth they offer a
variety of products from their smokable
pre-rolled joints as well as hemp flour
and variety of cbd tincture drops enjoy
the effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head all daggrass products are federally
legal for ages 18 and over and it ships
right to your door anywhere in the u.s
go to daggrass.com honeydew to check out
their products whether you're looking
for a new buzz or a chill way to enjoy
an old favorite dag grass will leave you
in a euphoric mood right now dadgrass is
offering my listeners 20 percent off
your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
you would [ __ ] catfish them to the
park and then sit there and watch these
losers yes what did they look like
listen if i was it was only two times
what would they be unsuspecting
one time one time it was like a like a
nice looking mexican guy and then the
second time it was like a little
chubbier
like bearded how old wait dude like i
would say probably 20.
i i thought they looked a lot older then
but i would say probably late 20s
knowing we're talking to 12 and 13 year
old oh and we would just laugh and watch
them and
literally just leave
if i if my daughter [ __ ] told me she
did that i'd like my parents didn't even
know they probably still don't imagine
could you imagine your kids doing that
[ __ ] outside i know one time her mom
uh caught like we actually left the chat
open and she saw that we were like
yeah flirting and she was like reading
it out it's nothing more awkward than
someone's mom reading your sexual
messages out loud while you're standing
there and you're
she was always getting me in trouble she
was always getting me in trouble she was
like
so crazy i remember the first time i
smoked weed she was like dude she was
already
we lived in different towns we were like
best friends when we were in third grade
and then in fifth grade i moved but my
our parents let us see each other like
every other weekend it was like an hour
away or something and um
so when i would go see her she was
always like
getting worse and worse you know what i
mean like she was changing and i was
kind of the [ __ ] in that neighborhood
she was getting finger blasted and you
know and she was like telling me all the
details
actually i'm wondering if we should
bleep her name out
um
i think i said it once
um but uh
but yeah she she she asked me if i
wanted to smoke and i was like yeah i
want to try smoking weed so she was like
we're going to go smoke at my friend's
house i was like cool so nighttime comes
this is that window moment where i'm
like i'm scared and she's like come on
you know don't be an idiot so we're
walking we're probably
we're 13 and we're walking 2 a.m in the
middle of the street we used to do the
whole time sneak out of the house was
the best it was so fun so fun to sneak
out so fun and my other friends were
different like i was sneaking out of the
house at the time but like i in my
neighborhood i had my friends i'd had a
bunch of boys coming in my window sneak
me out and we'd all go like swimming and
jump on a trampoline and it was like
very innocent like that was like my kind
of thing but her kind of thing was like
let's go smoke pot with these k you know
let's do it let's go tent pedophiles it
was always like something crazy um so we
go to these
this house and we go in
and it is like
i didn't know i didn't realize it then
but now i know it was like a trap house
like there was because there was no i we
went in a weird way and there was like
no way out and everything was like um
we were going to this room and the guys
that were there there's like it's me and
her
and we go into this room and there's
another girl that looks about our age
and all of these guys are like 18 or 19
and we're 13.
and we go into this room and they're
like it's like the whole house is so
dirty
it's like a hoarder's house almost where
there's just a trail to the room and
we're sitting and i'm like sitting on
this couch and
they close the door and when and then
they start locking it and there's like
four or five locks on the door
and they lock every single one of them
and i'm like uh okay and then um
they're definitely like adult older
grown men and that girl's been there
before you could tell she's comfortable
as [ __ ] she's smoking my friend's
smoking i smoke
are they they're all smoking and then
they find out it's my first time getting
high so then they're like
all right let's get her you know like
she's got to hit her first bowl and they
end up being so nice and so fun
and we ended up getting stoned with them
and like they smoked and then they're
like oh
and like i made it a thing we got high
and we watched some like live league
videos
and some [ __ ] on i think it was like
before world star it was something else
i don't remember ebom's world yeah i
remember you we were watching some of
those and then they unlocked all 17 of
their doors and let us leave but it was
really weird thinking back that we were
just
[ __ ]
these young 13 year old girls hanging
out with like 19 year old men yeah i
mean i wouldn't be a junior or a
freshman in college hanging out with
some eighth graders no that's insane and
getting them high yeah yeah yeah that's
the [ __ ] up point i had a friend that
um was in town with her sister who was
14 and we were smoking near her sister
and i felt weird and she's like oh she
smokes i don't let her when she's with
me but it's fine though i've already
started educating my dog like the
fentanyl [ __ ] that's going on right now
i already started talking to stella
about it i you know unfortunately a
friend of mine's daughter passed away
from it and she asked what happened to
his daughter and i wasn't gonna lie so
i've been teaching her about fentanyl
and pills and yup stuff that you do get
from the doctor can be deadly if you
don't take it properly and you know
don't trust everything uh that comes
from you know
a pharmacy
and i've taught her about marijuana
already i tell her i smoke it i tell her
it's medicine i tell her my doctor knows
uh prescribes it he knows i use it
um and that's what that smells like and
don't ever smoke cigarettes you know i
just i'm just being as real as i can
with her
because i feel like kids like you tell
me
how old were you again
that was 13 13 i mean that's five years
from now and that's kind of i feel like
it's getting younger and younger with
the older kids or their parents having
these things and you get a dirty
percocet or something and boom you're
[ __ ] dead so
yeah it's it's a wild [ __ ]
it's scary to think about all the things
you might miss all the lessons that
you're not thinking of like oh i didn't
even tell you that like right i was
telling sarah the other day i didn't
know i was pulling a toast out of a
toaster with a fork until i was 20.
i
swear
i swear i've been swimming with
electronics for years i'm telling you
that is not a lie i swear i didn't know
until like my college roommate was like
yes and she was like what are you doing
she like screamed and i was like she
even she almost killed me man she's
grabbing you back yeah i was like what
and she was like you can't do that
you're going to get electrocuted and i
was like i've been doing this for so
long you're right there are so many
things i have to teach her that i've
told her that all right i already my mom
forgot that electronics in the water is
a [ __ ] no-no you know don't ever put
a plastic bag over your head you know
all that don't get enough don't ever get
into an abandoned fridge or any kind of
fridge you're not getting out or dryers
washers and dryers like that [ __ ] you
got to tell kids that [ __ ] ah you got to
tell them in abandoned fridge you're
just locked in i'm sick that's probably
happened people's children have gone
missing in a fridge and they can't get
out and no one can wear them and they
just rot in a fridge i'm sick over that
that's sick that's [ __ ] up
yeah there is i mean it's crazy
the things that you survive when you're
younger and like you think about all the
close calls you had and stuff too well i
just think too being 16 we weren't
wearing seat belts until they made it a
law and then like all right we'll put it
on now i feel naked without it you know
but before
i don't remember putting the damn thing
on when i was 16. i was just so like
i didn't feel like i could die when i
was that young no one does yeah you're
bulletproof yeah invincible i mean
during the summer is me and i remember
one summer me and my friend andrea we
were probably 14 or 15. we just hopped
on the back of two
50 year old men's motorcycles who
offered us a joyride where are you
meeting all these there's pedophiles
everywhere they don't they're not
lagging yeah these people are around and
when you're and when we're 14 we're not
thinking that these guys want to [ __ ] us
like we're still we we have boobs and we
have like nice night like our bodies are
developing now but we're still like
mentally a little bit younger
so we're like these old guys just want
us to give us a ride because like
the same way like my uncle would be like
hop on you know what i mean like
that's a weird to say uncle
i don't have a dad
but it is weird to use uncle as an
example uncle's such a pervy
um position even if you're not a pervert
it just sounds like pervy in a story
but anyways we would hop on their bikes
go for joy rides not give a [ __ ] i
remember one time these dudes like hit
on us and my friend andrea told him to
leave us alone and they followed us in
the truck and she just took her whole
[ __ ] big gulp and just threw it in
the passenger seat window just soaked
their entire car with like
a fruit punch
yeah we didn't give a [ __ ] we didn't
think anybody was gonna attack us
and nobody ever did really
everyone let us off their bikes out of
their rooms i don't know how
but we got really lucky i feel like have
you ever had a um near-death experience
um yeah i've had a couple moments where
i'm like that was really close
me and my sister almost got in a really
really bad car accident once
and i actually don't even realize how
there was like a car like
uh a race car
in our hometown
doing
over a hundred yeah
and i mean came i i honestly feel like
sometimes you hear those stories where
it's like maybe i did die there was like
moments where me and my sister still
talk about it and that was like
years ago we're like maybe in another
universe we died because
neither of us understand how we did it
but we we made our right on a road where
the speed limit's already pretty fast
but there's cars going this way and
there's cars going this way and we're
making a right
so i only look this way because i don't
need to look this way to make a right
you know so i'm looking this way no
one's coming and as i turn and we're
already the car's already turned
um the car that's speeding doing like a
hundred is passing another car illegally
um oh so now he's in your lane he's in
my lane as soon as and i wasn't there a
second ago which is why he was gonna do
it so i turn and he's in my lane and i
mean he just
it had to have been like a centimeter
missed us and flipped into a ditch whoa
he crashed yeah oh holy terribly yeah
and they were both no they were both
okay they went to my high school
i recognized them they were both okay
um and we were like our car didn't even
get touched they had to get towed and
stuff but they yeah they were like in a
ditch and everything damn mm-hmm
um now you look right every time what do
you look right i look great
yep every time because of that one
moment
yeah you can't trust people not to pass
in an illegally you just can't trust
other people that's why whenever i see
people going on the highway so fast i'm
like it's fine if you're a good driver
but how do you trust these people not to
just not use their turning signal oh my
dad told me that one time i'm making a
right and cars are coming this way and
this car's got its blinker on but he's
been driving so long he sees that it's
not really slowing down i'm a new driver
i see the blinker and i'm like he's
clearly making a right turn but
he doesn't really know he doesn't have
his but he changed lanes but he wasn't
making a right that blinker's still on
so i'm about to enter out into his right
of way even though he has this blinker
on and my dad was almost got t-boned and
my dad was like never trust a blinker
don't ever sometimes people and then he
would point out look that asshole's
driving on the freeway right now that
blinker's been on for five minutes you
know what i mean so i was like oh and
now i don't care if their blinkers when
i sit there i will always sit down i put
i'm not a fast driver i don't need speed
i'm just right there you know i had a
weird moment when i was driving one time
this is
i don't i like to get super like
psychedelic and weird but i did have a
moment i was driving in l.a very
recently like three months ago where um
i
just like was going maybe 10 miles over
the speed limit it was on melrose on my
way back from the comedy store and then
i just was like you need to slow down
like to myself i was just like slow down
and i slowed down
and then um a car ran the red the red
light in the opposite lane like right
before me damn or you would have been
hit
and it was like i don't know why i
slowed down but i was like you need to
slow down and it was like right then and
i just saw the car come in
um will you tell me the story about your
first boyfriend
oh my gosh yes
yeah so uh i had my first boyfriend
um he was
this was in
middle school so this is in eighth grade
seven maybe seventh grade
seventh grade is when we met now he
dated a little bit from seventh grade to
eighth grade and he was like really
sweet but he actually had like a really
um
[Music]
he had like a really sad life like he
was he would tell me when we were
younger that like
his his mom would abandon him
and that you know they they would get
locked in the garage for days without
food like really super horribly abusive
and then he was living with his dad
after
being taken from his mom because she was
like on drugs and he was a really really
sweet kid he was super shy he was also
incredibly talented like
he was
such a good basketball player like our
entire town knew him for it everybody
was like saying that he would be able to
go into the nba
and he was like i don't know how many
points is a lot but i always in my head
remember him saying that he scored he
averaged like 30-something points a game
which is a lot
which is a lot average yeah that was
incredible yeah he was like really
really good and that number makes sense
right okay it's not like too far no okay
because that's what i remember he's that
good no he was so good
and um
yeah he just had like the worst life but
you know his his dad who i thought was
like a really good man but looking back
on it now he would lie to my mom when i
was in seventh grade and he would tell
my mom like i would go hang out with him
friday after school and he would tell my
mom um he would call my mom and say oh
yeah i dropped her off at her friend's
house for a sleepover because i would
tell my mom oh after i hang out at
jimmy's his dad's going to take me to
jess cause i'm going to stay there for
the weekend and i would just stay at
jimmy's for the weekend
really yeah
and then his dad would lie for me why
why do you think he did that because his
son wanted me his girlfriend to stay the
night and he was like
i thought he was a really good parent
but he was just like whatever you guys
want to do we can do
kind of parent
you know what i mean he was always
really nice but
um not really parenting no
no not really parenting at all
um and so we dated for a little bit but
then
we
you know it was like around that time
that a bunch of our friends started like
trying to drink and like you know that's
like about that age where everyone's
like trying to party for the first time
and jimmy and lives in this tiny tiny
[ __ ] town about like 25 minutes away
from me and it is like
the meth area of florida it is like so
gross like if you live there you're done
if you're you don't leave you're done
um and he just starts kind of changing
and so i break up with him because he
starts acting different
and he gets into like
like some gang [ __ ] in that area which
at this point i didn't even realize that
my town had like gangs and stuff but i
guess it did and um him and his friend
at this point are like in and out of
like um
like youth detention centers and like
juvie juvie
and he's like dating like really shitty
people he's dating some chick
and then you're still in touch or you're
just hearing about him no i completely
cut like i was we're not really in touch
at all i think i hung out with him like
a year after that a couple times and he
was
my friend i tell my friend tyler i'm
like jimmy was always really sweet and
he's like yeah to you he loved you but
he was a [ __ ] monster like that's how
he describes him he's like he was a
crazy monster animal and so he starts
doing all these drugs and then um he
gets this girl pregnant
and um
and they have a baby and you can tell
they're both on like bad drugs like the
pictures are like you can you know when
you see people's faces like sink over
time it starts like their eyes he starts
like looking like dead and then his
friend who we've known for years
suddenly he gets arrested he's in prison
i don't know what happens i just someone
calls me and he's like oh jimmy got
arrested and um
and
the friend got his head cut off what yes
do you know
and nothing else who was he [ __ ] with
so they had robbed
a local gang i think
and um i think that they had like
robbed them of and i think it was so
stupid i think they robbed him of um a
roll of lotto tickets scratch-offs
that's what he got his literally lost
his life
and then i don't know what happened that
put them to prison i don't know what
gang it was i don't know any details but
that's the story i heard
yeah
wow yeah
yeah and so he's still in prison
actually i think he he gets out i think
he might be out now i think i heard
that he was getting out like this year
jimmy mm-hmm
do you has he ever tried to reach out to
you mm-hmm i would i know no social
media no no jail correspondence
no i don't know if he would know where i
am yeah it's kind of hard to find people
from jail i think yeah but not if they
have internet you're an easy google
that's true
were you always kim congdon yeah you're
an easy one though yeah you know what's
crazy i still have
his pajama pants and i still wear them
often yes how long has he been impressed
[Applause]
how long has he been away
um he got locked up when i was 20
so 11 years you have he had his pants
for 11 years pants for like 15 years
yeah they're really comfortable i'm
going to give you a pair of night pants
right more done get rid of my friends
get rid of these prison [ __ ] pants
not at this point i've had them for so
long and i also have like such a
soft spot for who i know he could have
been could have been you know what i
mean like i saw him for like the sweet
abused child he was before
he got into drugs and i like to remember
him that way
so
um but yeah it's a [ __ ] up town it's a
[ __ ] up town there is incest rape
robbery gangs all in your town yeah fun
fun stuff in every town yeah yeah
there's crazy [ __ ] that happens in every
town every [ __ ] town there's some
weird [ __ ] that goes down in my town
like we were my parents were like always
the well i'm sure this was not just my
parents but my parents were like the
parents that the police knew
[Applause]
that has teddy bears from the trunk of a
cop car
sound off in the comments
[Laughter]
because your parents fight so hard they
have to bring you up
stick out a stuffy [ __ ] budget
yeah
it does make you feel better i'll tell
you i've seen them
my um
my daughter's mom dated a cop and he
gave my daughter like a little it was
like a little canine with a shirt on it
said elsa got no police or whatever i
was like he'll keep you safe
yeah my dad hit my mom rover's not
helping that's what was supposed to use
this to dab the blood
my mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
got a whole bit of [ __ ] stuff that
dude my parents various police
departments
going online without expressvpn is like
using your smartphone without a
protective case most of the time you'll
probably be fine but all it takes is one
drop on a solid concrete to make you
wish you had protected yourself
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airports your
online data is not secured any hacker on
the same network can gain access to and
steal your personal data your passwords
your financial details all that stuff it
does not take much technical knowledge
to hack someone most middle schoolers
could do it expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers can't steal your
sensitive data it take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get past expressvpn's encryption fire up
the app and click one button to get
protected plus
it works on all devices phones laptops
tablets and more so you can stay secure
on the go
look i use it here we use it at the
studio i use it at home alright
expressvpn is the only way to go to
protect your computers your online
privacy secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
honeydew and you can get an extra three
months for free yeah
expressvpn.com slash honeydew smoking
cannabis doesn't have to hurt in fact
there's a way to call flesk and enjoy
chili smoke with zero chest or throat
burn and the solution is a freeze pipe
freeze pipe makes a unique line of
freezable pipes bubblers bongs and more
the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers on every piece pop one of these
glycerin chambers in the freezer for one
hour and as smoke passes through the icy
chamber it's instantly chilled for a
bigger colder and smoother hit i use my
freeze pipe all the time okay easy to
clean throw that glycerin chamber in the
freezer for an hour clean it up boom i
don't cough my throat doesn't burn my
chest doesn't hurt and i've got the
small bubbler and i'm telling you i love
it it's the way to go comes in a really
nice steady secure case
good stuff y'all freeze pipes founders
we're tired of overpaying for pipes and
bongs at local head shops with state of
the art glycerin coils and water
filtration freeze pipes pieces cool
smoke by over 300 degrees most people
report the cough way less with freeze
pipe but everyone reports this is the
nicest cannabis smoking experience
they've ever had that's no lie if you're
tired of burning throats or coughing up
too much when you light up visit the
freezepipe.com and use code honeydew for
10 off that's
thefreezepipe.com use code honeydew for
10 off and say goodbye to harsh cannabis
smoke now let's get back to the do they
love making a scene well it's not my it
was my mom and my stepdad they loved
making a scene dude they love the cops
coming over i remember one time my mom
got arrested when they were fighting one
time and i was like crying with my
little stuffy and i was like watching my
mom in the back seat and i just watched
the [ __ ] she just [ __ ]
kicks the back window off the cop car
starts breaking it you can start seeing
the back back window the back back
window you can see it start coming off
and i say the cop is like she's gonna
break the window and they both run over
to [ __ ] and you're ah
and then three hours later this [ __ ] is
calling it's cold in jail i said yeah
[ __ ] it's cold what the [ __ ] are you
kicking out of competitions
with the stuff yeah
i was like asking for a blanket babe and
i'm like you guys are toxic they were
toxic
and so then she would get let out yeah
and then she'd be on three days and
they'd fight the next day no charge is
pressed no nothing yeah they would like
drop the charges on each other and
always call you don't do that [ __ ]
anymore no no now the city presses
charges really yeah because what happens
is a lot of women are scared to speak up
so they don't want to press charges so
like first i know for a fact santa
monica does so if you decide to not
press charges the city will mm-hmm so
your mom would have been [ __ ] back who
knows maybe she was trying maybe she was
who knows i don't know i didn't know the
details
uh yeah i remember some core
there's court for some stuff for sure
what did i give you a court i don't know
i just remember being in court
lollipop
a chocolate gavel
[Music]
[Applause]
they love to [ __ ] fight
those two and he would get arrested too
sometimes yeah sometimes i remember one
time the cops came and she
she pointed out all his weed
no
he i i remember he ran out of the house
with it before the cops got there and
was like dumping in the woods and she
brought the cops over the woods
yeah
yeah
how long are they together um they just
got a divorce like a couple years ago
but how many years are we talking um
since i was five and i'm 31. they're
doing 26 years of that behavior mm-hmm
what made her finally and you know
what's crazy is they got a divorce they
got blocked and i still think that
they're hanging out i still think that
they at least contact each other what
made your mom finally see i'm getting a
divorce
i think it was him i don't know i wasn't
there
you don't that's not a conversation you
have with your mom no
but you oh you know what i talked about
on the last podcast i think it was the
last time they fought and he pushed her
oh he pushed him he was like he pushed
her to the ground and he got her did he
get arrested i can't remember if he got
arrested this time but he he pushed her
and then he was like i'm done i'm gonna
have i'm gonna he's like i can't push
her
you know what i mean he's like i can't
get arrested
yeah you can and she'll and she and i
think i said in the last podcast like
she probably deserved it
because like she probably pushed she'll
push you to the edge you know what i
mean
yeah she'll do it to where you're like
[ __ ] you need to be pushed
do you ever fight with her like that
she's never been physical with you
because i asked because dads and sons
we have that moment and it's not the
dad's it's the son that thinks he's big
and bad enough to take dad you know what
what do you have you ever have a moment
like that with your mom my mom and my
stepdad i used to fight my stepdad
regularly i was a teenager we would just
fight
punch and stuff yeah he'd get in my face
i'd push him off he'd push me and we'd
start push you yes i couldn't imagine
pushing a 14 year old girl right that
could imagine
pushing my 14 year old son yeah but not
my not my daughter i could never imagine
putting hands on my daughter like that
yeah i think i've i've maybe shoved my
mom once
or twice as a teenager but like
she
has [ __ ] thrown vacuums at me
her horror story though she she broke
her leg one time and she was trying to
like come after me and she was trying to
you know throw [ __ ] at me we're in a
fight and i [ __ ] took her crutches
and i threw him outside
she couldn't get to me she was crawling
and she's so dramatic she was on the
ground like terminator
because if you know my mom she is
drama she is like one of those people
that like if if you push her
ah
like that like it's like she's very like
everything's a thousand percent
she's um a character
yeah she seems like a character he isn't
character it's the storm the storm
storm's coming the storms are brewing
and the storms are brewing she's wild
what were your were you she found my
stepdad in the ocean once huh
what do you mean yep
in the ocean she found myself in the
ocean once what do you mean found them
in the ocean he
went on a fishing trip and left her a
note instead of like talking to her and
telling her and it [ __ ] set her off
she thought he was she was like he's on
the boat with women no yeah and and she
went and [ __ ] called the coast guard
[Laughter]
was she on the boat with them
i don't and i've heard two different
versions and the version that i've heard
that she was on the boat with them my
stepdad says that she came on the boat
with them my mom says that she was
waiting by the deck
on the dock for them my steps my stepdad
says he was fishing and out of the fog
comes the coast guard with my mom on it
which is the funniest version of it and
[Music]
yeah you can see
just a light that's circling slowly a
white light that is crazy
in the ocean fishing she said he left a
note saying he was going to be back at
midnight it was 2 a.m he wasn't back yet
she was [ __ ] pissed not not worried
not but she was worried as the excuse
yeah and then she told the coast guard
they were missing they'd gone missing
she'd lied about the time so she's
coming tonight
just her curly hair flowing in the wind
oh yeah
oh
his um his brother says one of the
scariest things that ever happened is
one time they were just hanging out in a
room and my stepdad and his brother and
they were just talking
and they were getting ready to go out
and they were just having a normal
conversation sort of pre-gaming before
they went out and they're like where
where's uh where's mary and they're like
i don't know i don't know where she is
and they're like oh well i guess we'll
just go out without her and then right
then the closet door rips up and she
goes out in here
just listening to make sure that they
weren't talking about her
you know what she did to my dad
that's what i want to say do you have
any memories of them together no no
because they they got divorced when i
was five and i think everything before
that is kind of a blur
but my dad tells a story that um
he had this side hustle this is such a
[ __ ] up story
he had the side hustle um where he was
fishing for tropical fish
and he was selling them to like tropical
fish aquariums or whatever
the people that sell tropical fish and
he had like a whole set up he had built
this whole thing he had all this fish
and this whole system and he said he
probably had
15 20 grand
in fish in this room that he had just
like he was about to sell and him and my
mom got into a fight
the storm did not the storm bleached
every tank pulled bleach in them killed
them all
she killed them all the time
with those fish
fish aside she killed them all she did
she killed them all isn't that horrible
just because she's mad listen if you're
listening to this don't cancel me
it's not me i would never do that to a
fish i have empathy i go to therapy
jesus yeah
yes
yeah your mom she's crazy how do you set
boundaries with her then um like how do
you keep
contact yet enough distance that it
doesn't drive it's always a work in
progress
um
and we're currently working on it
is she aware of who and how she is
she is aware that i feel that she is
that way okay she's just like what's up
i'm fine she's like what's wrong with
you [ __ ] she's like you're grumpy
you're abusive
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so she's she's kind of aware
it's a work in progress it is
yeah it is a lot it is crazy because i
started doing therapy like um
probably five or six months ago like
actual i actually i've been trying to do
therapy for like the last 10 years but
i've only
up until this last therapist that i've
been seeing for six months i've only
been able to see therapists one time and
then i don't want to see them again i
would get like wildly embarrassed about
sharing things and then just like block
them
so i blocked like nine or ten therapists
before this
um and then so about this one's working
for you this is ready you wanna hear it
yeah
my therapist also works with prisoners
it's the only one i like
so i'm like there has to be something to
that
yeah your mom's been locked up yeah it's
gotta be something yeah
so yeah so i'm starting to realize a lot
of things it's very crazy because it was
very confusing me and my mom got along
really well until i was about 16.
and i couldn't figure out why and i
think it is because i turned 17 and
mentally she just has always been 16 and
she still is
yeah she still acts a lot like a high
school kid still yes high school drama
always never real drama it's always some
dumb [ __ ] yeah
yeah always and it's like and it
actually it [ __ ] you up because you
grow up and you don't know how to deal
with things like when i moved to la i
didn't realize that hitting people was a
big deal i was like yeah that's how you
solve in my head legitimately i was like
that's how you solve things how else
would you
there was no other there was not even
like i didn't even know there was other
options i'm gonna punch you i was like
who talks
i was like that's gay
that's all they're like you can't say
that
um either me about mr t i want to hear
this story i'm not not mr t from the a
team but we're going to call this person
mr t we're going to call this guy mr t i
was in high school
um and
my high school
they did some questionable things
like when they were teaching us about
like
world war ii they had us
go into the hallway of a building and
suddenly it was transformed into a
concentration camp and there was like
these people
and they were like that's not what i
thought you were gonna say i thought
you're gonna do like get on the wall put
your hands to your legs for the [ __ ] no
it was like all they were like
we go and we go into a room and suddenly
there's like a guy he's like i want blue
eyes and he's like drilling into a
student who's acting and then we and
then they're hurting us in a corner like
i was like whose idea was this they made
us like really go through it and like
hide in an attic it was nuts
yes
yes and they're like this is how anne
frank felt this would never fly today i
know at all that was an actual thing
that happened in my high school if you
went to my high school and you remember
that sound off in the comments
because in case people think i'm making
this up i want someone from my high
school to confirm i'm not yeah so my
high school is a little crazy they were
they they had some crazy moments i had
this teacher this history teacher and
this was in
i believe
10th grade is when i had him
he was my 10th grade teacher i believe
10th or 11th grade and he was my history
teacher and he was like i mean the first
day of school i was like this is the
coolest teacher you know the first day
of school they're all introducing
themselves he's like hi he comes in
strolls in the classroom he says he goes
he's got eyes kind of like yours he goes
ah my name's mr t
i teach his class it's going to be this
long he goes i want to say something
right off the bat
you see this picture of my son look at
his eyes
you see how they're all small like that
why don't you ever come in here and say
mr t you're high
he was definitely high and he was just
trying to make this announcement up
front that i'm not hot then i'm gonna
look like this every day i'm coming in
yeah this is what i look he was
basically like this is what i look like
none of you need to be reporting me he
was like my son looks high i look high
you have a problem with it let me know
and we're like cool this guy's cool
he's making comments like um
and and he's getting comfortable so
throughout the semester he's how old is
he
early 40s
late 30s early 40s and he's teaching a
while too at this school
i believe he had been teaching for five
or six years at school and i think he
was teaching at another school before
that
and he
got very comfortable throughout the
semester he would be the teacher that if
you like talked at a place like
he would be mad at you but he'd do it
almost like in a roasty way oh he made
us hold books above our heads and there
was always like humiliation tactics is
like what he like to use i remember at
one point he was like saying something
the first day of class he said
telling facts about himself and he was
like i'm this i'm from here and he was
like and the perfect height for a woman
is right here
the oh yes that's what he said they put
the thing he's like because the top of
their head could be a cup holder and he
said something weird like that and me
and my friends were like huh
and he was just always making comments
like
like um
this girl
she had ripped jeans on and he was like
how'd you get those holes in your knees
so he was always saying like little
things like that
and then at one point he puts on this
thing okay and i've been trying to find
this so hopefully one of your fans can
help me out he put on this movie for us
he was like got kind of lazy
mid-semester and he'd always tell us
about the student he'd talk about his
favorite student it was this girl he
says that they were the closest friends
ever and it was one of his most gifted
talented students his mouse pad was a
picture of him and her
yeah that's [ __ ] yeah that's the
crazy [ __ ] you've told me so far yeah
and then in in in class he'd had
students from the other hours the other
periods during their free time they'd
come in and give him a shoulder massage
while he taught us
just like
saying anything no this was like a loud
then
i don't know how to explain it a lot of
teachers like to get massaged
that's a thing um i've seen that a lot
and um and so he put on this [ __ ]
thing for us that was playing for like
days in our classroom during like finals
week and it was like this softcore
renaissance porn like it was like i
remember one of the scenes where like
all these people were walking into an
orgy and it said first serve first come
on as like the entrance sign it was like
a comedy
yes and it was like a soft core thing
and it was like just people [ __ ] and
like titties and i remember like he'd be
like if the principal comes in we have
to change it
and he was like putting and we would
just watch it every day he was just i
think he was probably getting off to all
of us watching porn in front of him
um and yeah and then i
on like i got a job at like the local
bar in our town
and so
every like all the teachers from my high
school would come there on the weekends
the police like i knew all the local
police and i was the food runner but i
would like bring out their beers and
stuff and so like i was like friends
with a lot of the adults so on the
weekends i would go play poker with my
teacher this guy mr t yeah so we would
go and i would meet up with like the
local police
and my teacher
and we'd all like play poker
and then
yeah at the end of the year uh it came
out that he was having a relationship
with that student he got fired it was
the next year the mousepad student the
mousepad student came out and said that
she had been abused and he had took the
best years of her life blah blah blah
and what he did was wrong and he
and blah blah blah and then um
we
this is so bad because we were young
but the this time you look at this
guys please don't judge me for this
because we didn't know and he was just
to me he was an awesome teacher who let
us watch raided our movies who i played
poker with on the weekends they've he's
seen me have a beer at a party he's been
cool
you know what i mean like uh and and and
then he gets cancelled he gets fired and
this is the next year and all of the
students who had them previously wore
team tea t-shirts really yes to support
of him
but it was all chicks because he was
only nice to chicks so there's like all
these high school hot chicks it was like
teen t-shirts and we we all got dressed
up the night before to support him so it
was like all the [ __ ] high schoolers
being like he did nothing wrong
we love him
yes
yep
man but he never made a move at you he
never made a move at me which is a
little insulting
i played a lot of books but he knew
because i was um
my boyfriend he played poker at my
boyfriend's parents house
and everyone knew this
no no i don't think my boyfriend's
parents knew how creepy he was
because he just did it in the classroom
yeah
yeah
we had a um
a shop teacher
shop teacher all
metal shop too
okay uh mr p will call him i feel like i
could say his name though because he did
get in trouble but i'm not going to mr p
and i remember the girls i guess
girls some of them start developing at
least breast seventh eighth grade
whatever and and some girls did and they
would tell us like this guy's looking
down my shirt and we nev we're like no
no he's not like yeah he's looking down
my shirt
and then
we had friends
you know our age would have younger
siblings and they would go through
middle school and have mr p's class and
those girls would say the same thing and
then i met um friends of friends who ten
years
like this guy definitely looked down
girls he's been looking at titties since
nom yeah since
so
um
the guy ends up retiring okay
and he turns his laptop in okay and
doesn't erase the child porn on the
school issued laptop no and they [ __ ]
finally get the guy they got him finally
got him and he was also taking pictures
not of the not of the girls he was
watching whatever was on that computer
was not of the students i believe it was
of whatever's on the dark web out there
and it's a school issued laptop and this
dumb ass didn't [ __ ] clear it
didn't wipe it and had been in fact
looking at
that [ __ ] and was looking down shop
teachers are perverts my our shop
teacher got caught too he would go smoke
weed with the guys
the students our shop teacher yeah with
some of the students who would go smoke
weed with the students and then he got
fired for making out with a girl nah in
the class and i was offended because i
didn't get
he didn't take me to smoke weed or make
out with me i couldn't even be one of
the boys i know you at all no he just
didn't get like neither of them i was
like please
yeah
um our softball teacher was dating a
student
or a female softball teacher my my the
female song female softball teacher
ended up having a relationship yeah
fired for updating a girl
on the softball team one of her the
students yeah
yep and then um and then i when i was in
high school i had a huge crush on the
soccer coach
huge crush and i wanted to bang him so
bad i was a virgin but i wanted to bang
him so bad how old was he he had to be
like 24 23
too young to be in high school you can't
be 23 hanging out with 18 year olds
it was like my senior year and i had the
biggest crush on him and um i remember
one time he was standing in the gym and
he had a coke and i asked him if i could
have a sip of it and he let me have a
sip of his coke like his strawberry
yeah i was like he wants me he wants me
that's kind of sexual you can't let an
18 year old who obviously has a crush on
you have a sip of your drink did he know
he had a crush
yeah he did yeah
um that's weird right how old were you
when you lost your virginity you said
you were a virgin 18 but you wanted to
go upstairs i lost my virgin virginity
when i was 17. but that's when i first
saw the soccer coach who was the boy you
was this boyfriend or it was a boyfriend
i lost my virginity to a virgin it was
very virgin i was a virgin virgin too
virgin virgin
team virgin version very uh very un
eventful
really i was like so it doesn't fit
i was like
fine did you finally do it it took a
while yeah i lost half my virginity in a
honda accord and i said we'll finish the
other half later
you're a lot of fun thank you for coming
on here and uh sharing these [ __ ] up
stories i needed not that this was light
in any way but it's definitely a little
bit more lighter episode i i [ __ ]
you're too much man i kind of want to
meet your mom i really do did she ever
come out for shows
yeah i've banned her for a year
but if she's good for one point i told
her she's good for one full year she can
come back to shows she heckled me the
last show at your own show just [ __ ]
being loud or taking pictures where it's
like you know the sound
of yeah yeah so i'm like sit down i'm
screaming at her i'm like
too much so but you'd love her she's
great
i want to see you two together that's
what i think would be funny i said you
the video of when we caught the aunt
making out with their nephew i'll send
you that video they're wrong yeah i want
to see that i got you um promote
everything you like again please yeah
you guys follow me on twitter
kimberlykongman on instagram kim kongden
check me out on twitch.tv queen kong1
and make sure you check out my podcast
broad topics
t-o-p-i-x and my other podcast this
[ __ ] anywhere that you find podcasts
they're really really funny check them
out on youtube check out the clips on my
instagram um and i put all my show dates
on my social media so
and secular thank you for having me you
got it girl i love this show i love your
fans everyone was so [ __ ] nice last
time yeah you got a really great
response yeah they love you go sweet
um as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you